let's talk a little bit
in more depth about how dna actually
copies itself how it actually replicates
and we're going to talk about the actual
actors in the process
now as i talk about it i'm going to talk
a lot about the three prime and the five
prime ends of a dna molecule and if that
is completely unfamiliar to you i
encourage you to watch the video on the
anti-parallel structure of dna
and i'll give a little bit of a quick
review here just in case you saw it but
it was a little while ago this is a zoom
in of dna it's actually the zoom in from
that video and when we talk about the
five prime and three prime ends we're
referring to what's happening on the the
riboses that form part of this this
phosphate sugar backbone so we have
ribose right over here five carbon sugar
and we can number the carbons this is
the one prime carbon that's the two
prime carbon that's the three prime
carbon that's the four prime carbon and
that's the five prime carbon so this
this side of the the ladder you could
say it is going in the
it is going let me draw a little line
here
this is going in the
three prime to five prime direction so
this end is three prime and then this
end is five prime it's going three prime
to five prime notice three this
phosphate connects to the three prime
then we go to the five prime connects to
a phosphate this connects to a three
prime then it connects and then we go to
the five prime connects to a phosphate
now on this end as we said it's
anti-parallel it's parallel but it's
oriented the other way so this is the
three prime this is the five prime this
is the three prime this is the five
prime and so this is just what we're
talking about when we talk about the
antiparallel structure these two
backbones these two strands are parallel
to each other but they're oriented
in opposite directions so this is the
three prime end and this is the five
prime end and this is going to be really
important for understanding replication
because the dna polymerase the things
that's adding more and more nucleotides
to grow a dna strand it can only add
nucleotides on the three prime end so if
we were talking about this right over
here we would only be able to add we
would only be able to add going that way
we wouldn't be able to add going we
wouldn't be able to add going that way
so one way to think about it is you can
only add nucleotides on the three prime
end or you can only extend you can only
extend dna going from five prime
to three prime if you're only adding on
the three prime end then you're going
from the five prime to the three prime
direction you can't go from the three
prime to the five prime direction you
can't continue to add on the five prime
side using polymerase
so what am i talking about with
polymerase well let's look at this
diagram right over here that really
gives us an overview of all of the
different actors
so here is just our dna strand and it's
we could imagine it's just somewhat
natural in its natural unreplicated form
and you could see we've labeled here the
three prime and the five prime ends and
you could follow one of these backbones
this three prime if you follow it all
the way over here
it goes this is the corresponding
five prime end so this
and this are the same strand and this
one if you follow it along
if you go all the way over here is the
same strand so this is a three prime end
and three prime end of it and then this
is the five prime end of it
now the first thing we and we've talked
about this in previous videos where we
gave an overview of replication is the
general idea is that the the two the the
two sides of our of our helix the two
dna the the the double helix needs to
get split and then we can build another
we can build another side of the ladder
on each of those two split ends you
could really view this as if this is a
zipper you unzip it and then you put new
zippers on either end
but there's a lot of it's in in reality
it is far more complex than just saying
oh let's open the zipper and put new
zippers on it it involves a whole bunch
of enzymes and all sorts of things and
and even in this diagram we're not
showing all of the different actors but
we're showing you the the primary actors
at least the ones that you'll hear
discussed when people talk about dna
replication
so the first thing that needs to happen
right over here it's all tightly
tightly wound so let me write that it is
tightly
wound and it actually turns out the more
that we unwind it on one side the more
tightly wound it gets on this side so in
order for us to unzip the zipper we need
to have an
enzyme that helps us unwind this tightly
wound helix and that enzyme is the
topoisomerase and the way that it
actually works is it it breaks up parts
of the backbones temporarily so that it
can unwind and then they they get back
together but the general high level idea
is it it unwinds it so then the helicase
enzyme and the helicase really doesn't
look like this little triangle that's
cutting things these things are actually
far more fascinating if you actually see
a
molecular structure of helicase but what
helicase is doing is it's breaking those
hydrogen bonds between our between our
nitrogenous bases in this case this is
an adenine here this is a thymine it
would break that hydrogen bond between
these two
so first you you unwind it
then the helicase the topoisomerase
unwinds it then the helicase breaks them
up
and then we actually think about these
two strands differently because as i
mentioned you can only add nucleotides
going from the five prime to the three
prime direction
so this strand on the bottom right over
here which we will call our leading
strand this one actually has it pretty
straightforward remember this is the
five prime end right over here so it can
add it can add going in that direction
it can add
going in that direction right over here
this is the five prime to three prime
so what needs to happen here is to start
the process you need an rna primer and
the character that that puts an rna
primer that is dna primase we'll talk a
little bit more about these characters
up here on the lagging strand but
they'll add an rna let me do this in a
color you can see
an rna primer will be added here and
then once there's a primer then dna
polymerase can just start adding
nucleotides it can start adding
nucleotides at the three prime end and
the reason why the leading strand it has
it's pretty easy is it this this dna
polymerase right over here
this preliminaries
and once again they aren't these perfect
rectangles as on this diagram they're
actually much more fascinating than that
you see a dna preliminaries up there you
also see one over here polymerase
this polymerase can just you can kind of
think of it as following the open zipper
and then just keep adding keep adding
nucleotides at the three prime end and
so this one seems pretty straightforward
now and you might say well wouldn't it
be easy if we could just add nucleotides
at a five prime end because then we
could say like this is going from three
prime to five prime well maybe that
polymerase or different preliminaries
could just keep adding nucleotides like
that and then everything would be easy
well it turns out that that is not the
case you cannot add nucleotides at the
at the five prime end and let me
let me be clear this three prime right
over here this i'm talking about this
strand this strand over here
this let me do this in another color
this strand
right over here
this is the three prime end this is the
five prime end and so you can't you
can't just keep adding nucleotides just
like that and so how does biology handle
this
well it handles this by adding primers
right as this opening happens it'll add
primers and this diagram shows a primer
as just one nucleotide but a primer is
typically several nucleotides roughly 10
nucleotides so it'll add
roughly 10 rna nucleo nucleotides right
over here and that's done by the dna
primase so the dna primase is going
along the lagging is going along this
this side this i could say the top
strand and it's adding
it's adding
the rna primer which won't be just one
nucleotide it tends to be several of
them and then once you have that rna
primer then the polymerase can add in
the five prime to three prime direction
it can it can add on the three prime end
so then it can just start adding it can
just start adding dna like that and so
you can imagine this process it kind of
you add a the the primase puts some
primer here and then you start building
from the five prime to the three prime
direction you start building just like
that and then you skip a little bit and
then that happens again so you end up
with all these fragments
of dna and those fragments are called
okazaki fragments
so the oka
okazaki fragments and so what you have
happening here on the lagging strand you
can think of it as why is it called the
lagging string well you have to do it in
this kind of
it feels like a sub-optimal way where
you have to keep creating these okazaki
fragments as you follow this opening
and so it lags it's going to be a slower
process but then all of these these
strands can be put together using the
dna ligase the dna ligase not only will
the strands be put together but then you
also have the rna being actually
replaced with dna and then when all is
said and done you are going to have a
strand of dna being replicated or being
being created right up here and so it's
all done you're going to have two double
strands one up here for on the lagging
strand and one down here on the leading
strand